in this problem the information below is
valid for a 10 Acre Site being sized for
a retention
Basin consider the Hy graph and
accompanying
information infiltration occurs for the
first 30 minutes at an even rate of 0.03
in every minute transpiration is also
constant at a rate of 0.01 in per
hour depression storage and surface
storage in the area in question includes
5,000 Gall of available
capacity if the depth of the retention
Basin on site cannot exceed 10 ft in
depth what is the required size of the
detention Basin in square
fet so this problem gives us a hia graph
showing the rainfall per minute over
10minute increments leading up to an
hour we are given the size of the site
and a number of other hydrologic things
that are occurring here so this is
essentially a water balance problem and
at the end we're being asked to solve
for the size of the detention
Basin so there's really
no page in the PE manual that's super
helpful for this problem but if you
really wanted to you could look
at page
section
6.5.1 for the surface water system
hydrologic
budget it's going to have some different
terms than what the problem is asking
for but it should give you the total
number of things that you would need to
sum and the total number of things that
you might need to subtract so let's go
go through one some of those now and we
can solve this problem so the first
thing we're going to want to
do is find our rainfall
volume and we're going to keep all of
our units in cubic feet since the
problem is looking for square feet at
the end
so it notes
that the hia graph shows us that
rainfall occurs in inches per minute and
these are over 10minute increments so
let's start by just summing the total
increments and we'll multiply by 10 so
we have
0.01 plus
0.03 plus
0.02 +
0.04 plus
0.02 plus
0.01 and that will get us
0.13
in times the 10 minutes that each of
those values is occurring
over well really yeah I guess that's
inches per minute since that's what this
unit is and that's what we summed so
this will cancel and this will give us a
total of
1.3 in from there we can do more unit
conversions so
1.3
in
time
1T over 12
intimes 10 acres because that's the size
of the site this is going to be raining
over times the conversion of
43560 fet squared per acre and that's
going to give us 47
1990 cubic
feet
2 let's look at infiltration
next so that's going to be equal
to
0.03 Ines every
minute times it says for the the first
30 minutes so let's multiply by 30
minutes and we'll continue on with the
unit conversion here so * 1T over 12 in
* 10 acres *
43560 ft squared per
acre and that's going to give us a
volume
of
D yeah cubic
feet so that's actually a large portion
of the amount that's getting rained on
here or of the amount of rainfall volume
I should say but
anyway next one we'll look at is
transpiration and that's going to
be 0 .01 in per hour
so this is a 60-minute hiat graph so we
can fortunately not change anything here
um so all that's going to be is
0.01 in per hour time 1 hour the total
length of our
event
times
1T over 12
in
time 10
acres time
43560 feet squared per
acre and that's going to
be
363 ft
cubed and finally we have our depression
storage and our surface area runoff so
we've
got depression storage
sorry for how sloppy that
is that's 5,000 gallons times another
unit conversion
of 1T cubed over
7.48
gallons and that's going to be equal to
just about
668 cubic
feet so from there what we have is is
our rain
volume and that's a positive number and
then we're subtracting
out infiltration we're subtracting
out transpiration and we're subtracting
out depression
storage so that's going to
be
47 190
363 and 668 and all of these are in
cubic
feet and that's going to give
us
13489 cubic
feet and knowing that the depth of this
can only be 10t we can
say / 10 ft gives
us 13
48.9 ft squared of available area to use
and our closest number over here is the
first one so that's all it takes to
solve this problem this is pretty much
just a long
grinding series of minor unit
conversions where you have to understand
how to use the hi graph given to you and
you have to understand a little bit
about the surface water hydrologic
budget just to recognize that the
rainfall is the number that you're
sizing for after you subtract out the
other hydrologic factors that are
occurring and that's
it